man kann mit vielen rechnen auf mallorca
sogar mit hai alarm aber
damit
er war gerade dabei seinen sonnenschirm
wegen des regens zu schließen als er vom
blitz getroffen und getötet wird ort der
tragödie der norden von mallorca am
malerischen strand der cala mesquida
gegen 16 uhr sonnen sich noch touristen
am strand wie aus dem nichts zieht
innerhalb weniger minuten ein sturm auf
blitze peitschen über die insel der 65
jährige schweizer bild entstand ausflug
gerade beendet als ein blitz direkt in
seinen sonnenschirm einschlägt er ist
sofort tot auch ein 51 jähriger mann aus
deutschland der sich in 15 meter
entfernung zum eigentliche einschlag
befindet bricht zusammen alarmierten
notärzte können den männern nicht mehr
hält die ehefrau des deutschen muss das
unglück hilflos mit ansehen sie wird
psychologisch betreut wie entstehen
diese tödlichen gefahren die
regentropfen einer gewitterwolke sind
elektrisch geladen
im oberen teil der beute sind sie
positiv und im unteren negativ dieser
ladungs unterschied führt zu einer
elektrischen spannung und wenn die sehr
hoch ist entlädt sie sich in einem blitz
wenn der einen menschen trifft können
bis zu 200.000 ampere durch den körper
fließen eine tödliche ladung auf
menschen in der näheren umgebung sowie
auf mallorca ca 15 meter vom
eigentlichen einschlag entfernt können
betroffen sein da der blitz war zunächst
in den boden abgeleitet wird der boden
aber wie hier der nassen sand den stopp
noch weiter leitet die stromstärke kann
zum sofortigen tod durch herzstillstand
führen doch wie kann man sich davor
schützen unbedingt zu vermeiden sind
hügel seen und flüsse sowie bäume und
masten denn blitze schlagen oft nicht
immer aber oft im höchsten punkt 1
unbedingt deckung suchen im besten falle
in einem haus mit blitzableiter oder in
einem fahrzeug aus metall wenn man
keinen schutz findet am besten in die
hocke gehen füße zusammen und arme um
die beine legen lebensgefährlich kann
das sein beidbeinig stehen zu bleiben
oder zu laufen die beiden mallorca
urlauber wurden von dem gewitter
überrascht hatten keine chance zu
entkommen
der wetterbericht im norden der insel
warnt deshalb auch in den kommenden
tagen kann es erneut zu blitzartigen
unwetter kommen
[Musik]